so we already went through a lot of the
allegations made in Marielle Trump's
book about Donald Trump Trump was
verbally abused by his dad wouldn't be
surprising he treats people like crap
often people repeat what they grew up
around Trump paid someone to take his
SATs new claim but wouldn't be hugely
surprising Trump has a learning
disability it's a new take on Trump's
cognitive appearing cognitively
compromised would not be hugely
surprising Trump's not really religious
he only goes to church when there's a
camera there or it's advantageous and
some I mean like none of the claims were
very surprising but the people around
Donald Trump have reacted explosively to
the forthcoming publication of this book
first you have Trump advisor Kellyanne
Conway who just lost it on Fox News over
this book she actually threatened
members of the media saying quote I
believe family matters should be family
matters which is that there's a whole
other story there where she and her
husband have been publicly tweeting
stuff related to their daughter but that
that's a different story
I believe family matters should be
family matters I think the thin-skinned
troubled living in a glass house
mainstream media members who think
people's families are their business
ought to really think thrice the next
time they do that sort of throwing in a
thinly veiled threat at the media there
is Kellyanne Conway of course you might
notice not actually refuting any of the
allegations that are made in meri
Trump's book then Trump press secretary
Kaley McKenna knee had a hilarious brief
statement about this saying I've not
seen the book and it's filled with lies
wait so you didn't see it but you know
what's in it listen very very carefully
here and this is going to be an
instructive moment for us
no response other than it's a book of
falsehoods and that's about it
self-aggrandizing offers
it's ridiculous absurd allegations that
have absolute no bearing and truth have
yet to see the book but it is a book of
falsehood alright thank you guys I have
yet to see the book but it's a book of
falsehoods so this is a great
opportunity to show you how this
administration tries to bully the media
and to foment the narrative of fake news
even when it doesn't exist the narrative
that reporters are biased is always the
priority for this administration Kaley
McKenna he clearly said there I have yet
to see the book but it is a book of
falsehoods ABC reporter Jonathan Karl
quoted her verbatim tweeting quote press
secretary offers an interesting take on
the Mary Trump book I have yet to see
the book but it is a book of falsehoods
so that's Jonathan Karl quoting Kaylee
McCann aney verbatim Kayla McKenna Kaley
McKenna knee tweets in response don't be
disingenuous Jonathan Karl though I
don't possess a physical copy of the
fictitious book since I'm not in the
press corps my inbox has been flooded
with the false claims and excerpts from
the book you know how this works
and yet here you are but again her claim
was not I've not seen a physical copy of
the book but I know what's in it and
it's filled with lies and here are the
specific lies her claim wasn't I haven't
seen the book but I know what's in it
and thus I'm able to intelligently
comment on her claim was only I haven't
seen the book and it's a book of
falsehoods and Jonathan Karl quoted her
verbatim but more importantly this is
how they turn the narrative on the
reporter if there are lies in the book
tell us which are the lies and as of
right now they have not substantively
refuted any of the claims all of the
claims are completely consistent with
everything we know about Donald Trump we
say it's a lie or Trump says it's a lie
is not really anything and it's
instructive in how they turn this
completely around and make it about the
reporter make it about the fake news
media when really I mean I I don't I
don't want to deflate the importance of
this book because it's a powerful book
to hear from someone that that was
an insider to the Trump family although
she's now estranged but nothing in the
book is even that notable because it's
also in line with what we've observed
from Donald Trump and when they come out
and just say it's all lies well is it
because it all sounds super consistent
in the picture at paints of an insecure
narcissistic man with delusions of
grandeur willing to do whatever he
believes in the moment will help him get
ahead and that's really the picture that
we've that's the Donald Trump we've
known and that's exactly the picture
that's painted in the book and so far no
specific refutation of anything that is
in there we're going to take a break and
coming up after the break we are going
to talk about a Mississippi Election
Commissioner who is furious that quote
the blacks plan to vote yeah that's
coming up next one of our sponsors is
privacy calm they're giving you $5.00
when you sign up for their completely
free service at privacy calm slash
Pakman I've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before it's a lifesaver
and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone instead of actually using your
real credit card number the privacy app
and the browser plugin let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even autofill the card number with
one click and the payment is taken out
of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them any time you want so when
you do this it means you're not going to
be charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance I love using free trials
because I know I won't be charged when
the trial is over if I use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity private by not telling
companies who you are you're keeping
your bank or credit card info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want privacy also
offers a $10 a month plan that gives you
one percent cashback and lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a $25 a
month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create 60 card
numbers a month and much more but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like I
said you'll get $5 to spend when you
sign up at privacy calm slash Pakman